[music]
Enemy
down.
Yeah,
water.
Holy
Spirit.
>> [music]
>> That's just
[music]
Hello.
Welcome everybody. It's good to see your
faces after being out last week with all
of the fun weather. Um
Glad to have you back. My name is Karen
Miner. My pronouns are she, her. Welcome
to all of you here. Welcome to those who
are watching online. It is good to be
together again. Um, I have just a few
announcements, some things happening uh
soon tonight and over the next couple
weeks. First of all,
uh we have uh Hat Creek Burger Company
tonight. This is the first Sunday in
February. We made it out of January. Uh,
and on the first Sunday of every month
around here, we go to Hat Creek after
for dinner after the service. That's Hat
Creek in Saxi off of 78. So, we hope to
see you guys there immediately after the
service. Uh secondly,
next week is a Super Bowl and because we
are an evening church and because we
want everybody to be able to do all the
things, uh we are adjusting our service
time. So next Sunday we'll be having
service at 3:30 p.m. Not 5. So don't be
here at 5 because we'll be all done. Uh
3:30 p.m. next Sunday uh because of the
Super Bowl. So we hope you'll be here
for that. And then also, please save the
date for our State of the Table meeting
that's coming up in a couple weeks on
Sunday, February 15th at 3:30 p.m.
before the service. State of the table
is basically like State of the Union
only much, much smaller. It is about our
community here at the table. you can
hear what's going on. Um, and uh, you'll
hear about different ministry groups and
it is such an informative
uh, meeting. So, we hope you will be
there for that.
We have our accessibility bucket over
there on the credenza. If you need a
fidget, noise cancelling headphones,
something to keep your hands busy during
the service, please go grab something
out of there. Just put it back before
you leave. Um, all right. I don't know
about you, but it has been a lot the
last couple weeks, month. There's a lot
of unrest. There's a lot of um
uncertainty and struggle and injustice
out there. So,
in that vein, let's just take some time
to be together tonight to not push away
what's happening, but instead center
ourselves
on Jesus,
on our hope,
the fact that we're not alone in the
midst of everything [music] going on.
So, just take a moment, settle yourself,
close your [music] eyes.
Land [music] here now.
Take a deep breath in
and out.
One more time. Breathe in.
Breathe out.
These words were written by [music] poet
Amanda Gorman in response to the killing
of Alex Prey [music] by ICE agents in
Minneapolis.
We wake [music] with no words, just woe
and wound. Our own country shooting us
in the back is not [music] just
brutality, it's jarring betrayal.
Not enforcement, [music]
but execution.
A message.
Love [music] your people and you will
die.
Yet our greatest threat [music] isn't
the outsiders among us, but those among
us who never look within.
Fear not those without papers, [music]
but those without conscience.
Know that to care intensively,
united, [music]
is to carry both pain, dark horror for
today [music]
and a profound, daring hope for
tomorrow.
We can feel we have nothing to [music]
give and still belove this world
waiting, trembling to change.
If we cannot find words, may we find the
will.
If we ever lose hope, may we [music]
never lose our humanity.
The only undying thing is [music] mercy.
The courage to open ourselves like
doors,
hug our neighbor, [music]
and save one more bright impossible
life.
Thank you, Karen.
[music] Wow, that's really powerful. If
you guys want to stand with us, we're
going to [music] get started with our
worship tonight. And um the theme of
sort of the lyrics as we kind of go
through this set is this [music] bigger
idea of Jesus talking to his [music]
disciples and asking them when several
of them had decided to turn away and and
leave. And he turns [music] to the ones
who are remaining and says, "Do you want
to go too?"
And then [music]
Simon Peter responds and says, "Where
else would we go? Who would we turn to?
[music] For only you have the words of
life."
>> [music]
>> And tonight as we go through this set, I
encourage you to think back and remember
if [music] you have some words that you
have received, maybe through reading
scripture, [music] maybe a prayer that
someone has shared with you. Um maybe
something from one of these [music]
services um that is a word of life to
you that you can cling to when the
darkness is crowding in. Um or maybe
it's just listening to these [music]
lyrics tonight and letting them be light
and life um to us on our path. But
[music] let's just hold that in our
hearts together, remembering that it's
Christ that we turn to. [music] He is
our life. He is our lifeline. Um [music]
and that is a belief that we hold in our
hearts. That's what we ground ourselves.
It's what we're anchoring ourselves
[music] in um through these dark and
confusing times. [music] Um, and
hopefully in our worship together
tonight, we have that sense among us
that he is with us and he is bringing
his life.
[music]
I searched the world, [music]
but it couldn't [music] fill me.
meant [music] empty praise,
treasures that fade,
never enough.
[music]
But you came along.
You put me back together
and every desire [music and singing]
is now satisfied
here [music] in your love.
>> [music]
>> Oh, there's nothing
better than you. Oh, [music] there's
nothing [singing]
better than you. [music] Oh, there's
nothing
nothing is [singing and music] better
than you.
I [music] know it's true.
I'm not [music] afraid.
show [music] you my [singing] weakness,
my failures and flaws. [music] You see
them all. You still call me friend.
[music]
>> It's the God of the [singing] mountain.
>> It's the God of the valley.
[music]
There's [singing] not a place your mercy
and grace won't [music] find me
[singing] again.
Oh, there's [music and singing] nothing
better than you. Oh, there's nothing
[music]
better [singing] than you. Oh, there's
nothing
nothing [music and singing]
is better than you.
>> [music]
>> Oh, there's nothing [singing]
better than you. Oh, [music] there's
nothing [singing]
better than you. Oh, there's nothing
[music] nothing is better than you.
I know it's true.
>> [music]
[music]
>> You turn morning to dancing.
You [music] give beauty for ashes.
You [music] turn shame into glory.
You're the only one who cares. [music]
You turn moaning [singing] to dancing.
You give beauty [music and singing] for
ashes.
You turn [music] shame [singing] into
glory.
You're the only one who can. [music]
You turn [singing] graves into gardens.
[music] You turn [singing] bones into
armies.
>> [music]
>> You turn seas into highways. You're the
[singing] only one who can. [music]
You're the only one who can. [music]
You're the [singing] only one who can.
[music]
>> All right, we're going to dismiss our
kids to go [music] to their kids'
classes with their teachers over by
these double doors. You guys have a
great night.
Thank [music] you, Maggie and Harper and
Eve. And I think maybe Katie's back
there. Thanks for everyone who's helping
out tonight with those kids.
And we are going to transition into the
prayers of [music] the people. Um,
so feel free to lift up a person or a
situation that's on your heart when we
get to that part of the prayer, but
we'll follow along and read [music] the
parts in red together aloud.
Jesus, for this city of Sax, Texas, and
for every city and [music] community and
all who live in them, we pray to you for
[music] the good earth that you have
given us and the wisdom and the will to
conserve it. We pray to [music] you for
the old and the sick. For the widow and
the orphan, for the injured [music] and
the suffering. We pray to you for the
poor and the oppressed, the unemployed
and destitute, [music] for prisoners and
captives and all who remember and care
for them. We pray [music] to you for the
vulnerable, the marginalized, and those
unjustly targeted for their gender,
sexuality, race, [music] or other
perceived difference. We pray to you for
those experiencing loss, loneliness,
[music]
and disconnection. And for those
struggling with mental and emotional
[music] health, we pray to you, Lord. We
know that you love us and that you hear
us. So we lift these names and
situations [music]
up to you.
Pray for [music]
pray for Mary and [music]
Jessica.
For the names and moments that we have
spoken aloud and for those that we have
kept in our hearts, we [music] pray to
you that they may have life and light,
healing and hope, peace and a deep
[music] sense of your presence. Amen.
It doesn't matter [music and singing]
if the whole world turns
away. [music]
I will stay with you, my God.
I [music] will stay [singing] with you.
It doesn't matter if the whole [music]
world [singing] turns
away. I will stay with you, my God,
[music] I will [singing] stay with you.
Cuz where can I go? [singing] Where can
I [music] go? Where can I go
when [singing] only you have the words
of life? Only [music] you have the words
of life. Where can I go? [singing] Where
can [music] I go? Where can I go?
When only you have the words
[music and singing] of life? Only you
have the words.
[music and singing]
>> [music]
>> It doesn't matter where we're going.
[singing]
If you will go with me, [music] I will
stay with you. My God, [singing]
I will stay with you.
It [singing and music] doesn't matter
where we're going.
If you will stay [singing] with me,
[music]
I will stay with you, my God.
I will stay with you.
[music and singing]
Cuz where can I go? Where can I go?
[music] Where can I go? [singing]
Cuz only you have the words of life.
Only [music] you have the words of life.
Where can [singing] I go? Where can I
go? Where [music] can I go? [singing]
When only you have the words of life.
Only you [singing and music] have the
words.
Only you [singing] have the words of
life. Only you have the words.
No other.
No [music] other [singing] will's going
to satisfy.
No other word's [music] going to
[singing] be my life. No other love that
I'm turning to. Jesus,
[music and singing] you're my
breakthrough.
No other will's going to [singing]
satisfy.
No other word's [music] going to be my
light. No other will love that I'm
turning to. Jesus, [music and singing]
you're my breakthrough.
No other world's going to satisfy.
No other words, God. I'll
[music and singing] be my light. No
other love that I'm turn into. Jesus,
[music and singing] you're my
breakthrough.
Jesus, [music and singing] you're my
Jesus, [music] you're my breakthrough.
[music]
It doesn't matter if the whole [singing]
world turns
away. [music]
I will stay with [singing] you, my God.
I will stay with you.
It [music and singing] doesn't matter if
the whole world turns
away. [music and singing]
I will stay with you, my God.
I will stay with [singing] you. I will
stay. I [music] will stay with you my
God.
I will stay [singing] with you.
[music]
I [music] have decided [singing]
to follow Jesus.
I have decided [singing]
to follow Jesus. [music]
to follow [music] Jesus.
No turning back. [singing]
No turning [music]
back.
The world behind [singing]
me.
The cross before me. The world
[music and singing] behind me. The cross
before [music and singing] me.
The world behind me, [music] the cross
[singing] before me. No turning back.
No [music] turning back.
Though none [music] go [singing] with
me, still I will follow.
Oh [music and singing] none go with me.
Still I will [music] follow.
No none [singing] go with me. Still I
will [music] follow.
No [singing] turning back.
No turning back. [singing]
[music] No turning back.
No turning [singing and music] back.
No turning back.
>> [singing]
>> No [music] turning back.
I have [music] decided [singing]
to follow Jesus.
I [music] have decided [singing]
I have decided [singing and music]
to follow Jesus.
>> [music]
>> No turning back. [singing]
No [music] turning back.
This Christ, we have decided that you
are our anchor.
You and your life inform the way that we
live, the way that we love,
the way that we defend.
God, you are our source.
And when the world around us would like
to twist and turn and even weaponize
your words, God, we look to Jesus.
And [music] we build our life on him,
on the love of Christ that sacrificed
itself, that laid [music] itself down on
behalf of others,
that fought for the widow and the
orphan,
that made space and room for every story
and every race and [music] every human
life.
God, would we make room for one another?
Would we carry your love, your nature,
[music]
your justice
into this hurting world?
Would your light come [music] with us
into darkness?
Would your forgiveness,
your redemption
cover us?
And would it transform us? Would it
change us?
God, make our world different.
Make us different.
We [music] need you.
We need your mercy.
We need your hope.
It's in Jesus name we pray and believe
these things.
Amen.
I just want to [music] take a second to
thank this team. I don't do it often
enough and I'm just really grateful for
you guys and what you guys create here
for us each Sunday night. So, thank you
all for the time and the effort and the
energy. Can you guys just give them a
hand?
It's really a gift to share [music] in
music together. Um it doesn't happen in
many spaces anymore and [music] I'm just
super super grateful for them. Um and
I'm grateful for you guys. Thanks for
joining in with us. Would you go ahead
and turn to the person beside you and
say the peace of Christ be with you and
then Brett will start our message.
[music]
Well, grace and peace and uh welcome
welcome to the table. Glad to uh to be
with you all and uh yeah, it's good good
to be with you. So, um as always, that
includes those join us online. love you
all lots and uh yeah, just good to be
together after a week away. I uh I won't
lie, I like watched a lot of football
last Sunday. [laughter]
Usually I have to record it, you know,
and watch it later if I'm going to get
to it at all. And I was like, "Oh, look
at me." 300 p.m. 5:00 p.m. just watching
football. You know, it's nice. But um
yeah, but it was it was good. But I am
glad to be glad to be back with you all.
So, um, we are in, uh, part three in our
series titled No Fear in Love, a study
of First John. And we're taking kind of
five weeks to like walk through this,
uh, through this wonderful New Testament
book. And, uh, so the title of my
message uh, specific to tonight is uh,
three expressions of the ego. And, uh,
our text is, uh, we're in 1 John chapter
2 uh, verses 15-1 17. And uh I'll be
reading from the message uh a paraphrase
of the Bible and it says this. Don't
love the world's ways. Don't love the
world's goods. Love of the world
squeezes out love for the father.
Practically everything that goes on in
the world, wanting your own way, wanting
everything for yourself, wanting to
appear important has nothing to do with
the father. It just isolates you from
him. The world and all its wanting,
wanting, wanting is on the way out. But
whoever does what God wants is set for
eternity.
That's beautifully put. One reason I uh
I like the message uh which is like I
mentioned a paraphrase and not an exact
translation of the Bible particularly
for a community like ours uh where
there's been so much often a lot of hurt
kind of connected to you know scriptures
and certain ways of reading it and
interpreting it is that a paraphrase
does allow that scholar who's kind of
writing it to um kind of work in in
essence the the meaning um as best they
can tell from the words into it. which
means if you're doing like a Bible study
or like trying to do, you know, write a
theological paper, you don't want to
work from a paraphrase. But if you're
just like trying to read the Bible and
understand it, a paraphrase is an
excellent way to go. Uh so es especially
the the message, I think Eugene Peterson
just did a fantastic job with um with
that. And uh yeah, so I I will kind of
want to throw that out there as a
encouragement. If you've read tried to
read the Bible before and you're kind of
like, "This is like over my head. I do
not know what this is getting at." Uh
Eugene Peterson does a wonderful job of
kind of putting it in just common
language. Um to uh kind of contrast it a
little bit, I want to go ahead and read
the um New International Version, the
the translation of this same passage,
and we'll get into some kind of draw out
some kind of uh you can so you can see
the interpreting that Eugene Peterson's
doing. So here's um how it just reads in
like a translation. Do you not love the
world or anything in the world? If
anyone loves the world, love for the
father is not in them. For everything in
the world, the lust of the flesh, the
lust of the eyes, and the pride of life,
comes not from the father, but from the
world. The world and its desires pass
away, but whoever does the will of God
lives forever.
So that's same passage, first
paraphrase, second a translation as as
best the NIV kind of team could get at
it. And uh so it's you know it's certain
the reason I went with this and we'll
see as we go to the message like I'm
working from the paraphrase of Peterson
is because I think some of this language
you know the world the world the world
uh as opposed to Peterson goes with the
world's ways the world's goods. I think
that's that's an example where the
language of ways or goods is not in the
original. Does that make sense? That's
why the NIV doesn't include it. But what
he's doing there is he's the he's
getting at the meaning. What does John
write when he says the world? And that's
kind of the trick, right? As modern kind
of readers and listeners, we hear it and
is kind of hear the Bible so to speak or
John ranting against the world. And you
can see where pastors and churches have
really taken that idea and kind of run
with it in what I believe what Eugene
Peterson believes is kind of some
unhelpful directions, you know. So this
kind of to some ears it can really sound
like just basically a very negative take
on like life. [laughter] uh creation um
even you know just kind of like the body
and uh it's almost becomes a critique of
like anything fun or enjoyable
like um you know so for example there's
some traditions in Christianity that are
like very against dancing you know it's
like against because that's worldly
you know uh I I think this is kind of a
disaster and
So yeah almost like enjoying oneself
starts to fall under what people imagine
you know the the world to be and uh and
it similarly there was that language in
the NIV of you know the lust of the
flesh the lust of the eyes the pride of
life
um which we hear that language like oh
lust okay sex so sex is bad you know we
kind of get into this like a ve a a very
um kind of negative frame you know in
terms of what John's getting at does
this kind of make sense and so that's
where we can kind of hear or read a
translation like the NIV and kind of get
off track. So, um I think this is where
Peterson is much um much much better
with his kind of interpretation there of
the the lust of the eyes, the the pride
of life and all that as a kind of
restless craving, a kind of selfish
wanting. So, um what I want to do is
kind of let's go back to the very
beginning and kind of unpack this like
okay so if it's not like if John's here
isn't getting at like okay so just we
don't want to be about the world and
anything enjoyable. Okay, if it's not
about that, well then what is what is
it? You know, what is what is maybe John
getting at? Um, so he opens here with
don't love the world's ways. Don't love
the world's goods. Okay, so what are
these like ways of the world? I'm going
to read you two quotes, different
authors. First, Richard Roar, second
Maggie Ross. Quote them often. I I adore
these writers. I love them. And uh so
this is kind of their take on on the
world. Um, so Roar writes, "The world in
the Bible is the system of mutual
flattery and constant rewarding of the
false self." Jesus said, "In the world
system, you will have trouble, but be
brave. I've already overcome it." He
overcame the system, seduction, and
illusion by living inside an utterly
different frame of reference, the
eternal reign of God. Uh, here's Maggie
Ross.
The world in this context does not mean
the creation which is good but rather
the arena of illusion [clears throat] of
power struggles and conspicuous
consumption imagined in the mind but
acted out in the suffering of the
material creation and the body. Right?
It adores only what it can consume and
lives for the adrenaline rush of power
over people and things.
I think like this is a much better
critique uh and a much better angle at
kind of what are we getting at when when
the biblical writers are kind of
critiquing the world, right? This is
where I think Peterson's better to kind
of interpret as the world's ways, the
world's goods. you kind of at least
start getting a hint, you know, kind of
going that direction in your mind as
opposed, you know, to something, you
know, like dancing, you know, you can
see where in light of those
interpretations like it's a much richer
um I think just a better better
perspective. Um that kind of opens
things up for us. Um and in essence, we
might even say, you know, not only is
creation good, but we could even say the
world is good in this specific sense,
right? The world's good. It's the ways
of the world, the inquisitive, power-
hungry systems of flattery and illusion
constructed by human egos. Uh these are
not so good to uh to put it, you know,
mildly.
We'll keep going. This is uh verse 16.
Practically everything that goes on in
the world, wanting your own way, wanting
everything for yourself, wanting to
appear important, has nothing to do with
the father. So these will be this will
be kind of the rest of the message.
We'll be unpacking these these kind of
three um expressions of the ego. So
let's kind of um take these apart one by
one. So first expression wanting my own
way.
We'll call this control and certainty.
You know you don't have to raise your
hand but anyone a little bit into
control and certainty [laughter]
you struggle with anxiety it's possible
that's I can I'll raise my hand. This is
This is definitely mine. Um I uh
yeah, I mean I think of even like the
little the burger commercials. Maybe is
it Burger King right now? You know, the
have it your way. And there's almost
like nothing we like so much as like
having it our way. And that's just like
yes, this is my jam, you know? And uh
and I to be clear too, I I want to name
um I think wanting our own way becomes
kind of egoic and problematic only in in
a specific sense. Like I don't think
it's necessarily just about like you
know if you have a preference well how
dare you that's so selfish you know you
have you have a desire oh my you know
like no um it's not it's not that I
think sometimes in kind of Christian
circles
um being selfish was kind of framed as
it almost being bad for anyone under any
circumstances to ever say well I have a
desire or I have a preference on this
you know um I think often not always but
often Christian women in particular were
kind of put into
framework or kind of almost pushed to be
a kind of um you know like sort of such
an extreme version of selflessness so to
speak you know this kind of we like
became a kind of hollow empty person you
know what I mean like I don't have any
desires I don't have any opinions you
know I'm just here to serve and take
care of the children and my man you know
or something like you can see where that
gets real weird and bad you know just
toxic and okay so um so again I don't
have that that's not what I'm what I'm
talking about. I don't think that's what
John um is getting at. What what I have
in mind here um is, you know, when kind
of my ego kind of takes over and I start
to relate to everyone and everything
kind of through the lens of my own kind
of wants and desires. you know, in
essence, um, it's it's almost like kind
of an extreme of, you know, where ego
would say like it's my world,
you all just happen to inhabit it. You
know, this is where it's like, oh, this
is a problem. You know, this is uh this
is an issue. And uh this is a a person
when we get in this mode this is like a
very difficult person to be for example
married to you know this is a difficult
person to befriend
and uh and it's easy I think it's in a
strange way kind of like all these it's
so easy to see in others you know what I
mean like they're such a narcissist
they're such a this or that you know it
often becomes quite hard to kind of see
some of our own um issues here you know
I mean or acknowledge them like yeah
like in essence um is at least some of
this sickness in you too. You know, it's
in me. [laughter] Um so that's first
wanting my own way. This control and
certainty. Second, wanting everything
for myself. John writes, I'm going to
call this um acquisition and possession.
In essence, if kind of, you know,
wanting my own way is about kind of
controlling like others in the world
around me. This is this wanting
everything for myself is a kind of uh we
might call it like a consumerism uh run
a muk you know this habit of
inquisitiveness. If I had to kind of sum
up the western world in one sentence it
would be something like this that we
tend to prioritize acquisition you know
the the getting of things positions
titles money and so on um above
relationships
and even simply kind of the art of even
just living. you know, it's sort of like
we just get very locked in on this um
this acquiring and acquisition. There's
a kind of uh cultural picture of this
that I've observed recently is the habit
of um some of the kind of um very uber
kind of wealthy often tech CEOs but not
always um to be purchasing bunkers and
parcels of land in like rural places.
Where have you heard of this? [laughter]
Um so you know the idea being if a kind
of existential threat comes true you
know some boweapon disaster nuclear war
AI run you know something whatever kind
of things we're facing it actually
happens well then they'll just like
scurry off to their bunker and you know
the rest of the world it may burn you
know but
I'll be okay you know that is [laughter]
that is such That is just a perfect
picture of egoic illusion and fantasy
and delusion. You know, like this idea
of I alone apart solitary from all these
other humans, you know, I shall carry
on, you know. Um, yeah. No, no, this is
this is uh
yeah, this is the kind of height of of
illusion, you know. And uh almost like
in a way maybe a lesser version of this
would be you know every time I kind of
buy into the fantasy that like more
things gathering up more things rather
than having better relationships
uh to God to myself to others as long as
I kind of in in a mode where I'm
thinking like that's the key to my peace
and happiness you know uh it's it's like
uh a little bit of this this kind of its
ego kind of jumping out in this way. Um
but in so many ways you that's like a
fantasy I think the western world that's
kind of we very much you know bought
bought in on this. Um another example of
this would be of kind of desire for
acquisition and possession would be um
Dr. Sarah Payne. She's a historian. You
might have seen it. She's like kind of
YouTube famous. Um, and I saw an
interview with her on um the Doresh uh
podcast and she's a professor of like
East Asian history but including kind of
Russia and uh she had had a fascinating
talk and one of the things she talked
about was the fact that after um was
basically she was in Russia right after
the Berlin wall fell and lived there for
like a few years. So she kind of got to
see like this transition like kind of
Soviet Russia and what that experience
was like and then the wall comes down
and then kind of you know different
economy and such starts to percolate and
it's this new day and she's there for a
few years like for that transition. So,
it kind of gets this like behind the
scenes, you know, look at it. And uh she
said one of the um events or one of the
things that kind of led to that though,
the wall coming down and such was um the
way well that um American television
started getting smuggled in to communist
countries including like East Germany
and Russia as well. And uh what part of
what happened there was there were
moments where uh sometimes it was during
a show, sometimes it was like even
during a commercial where you would get
a glimpse of American supermarkets
and it like blew their minds like
because just the grocery stores they had
are like not so good. and suddenly they
see on their screen this grocery store
with you know not a hundred but like
thousands of products
and it was just like oh I mean 17
different types of peanut butter you
know it was just like wealth and
opulence like they never dreamed and
they realized like oh propaganda like
they're feeding a story you know it just
started to like undermine you know the
the narrative now the twist is though
that because she was actually there for
this transition, she saw that that while
they kind of latched on to the visions
of like basically acquisition, you know,
getting all these things and having like
a better life and you know all that,
they what they latched on to was kind of
that vision. What they didn't realize
she said came along with that was the
pace and hours of work. She said when
that new um economy came along, they
weren't quite prepared for like 40, 50,
60, 70 [laughter] hour work weeks. You
know what I mean? In essence, you pay
for those things. Does that make sense?
It would be easy to see kind of the
vision, the dream, the oh yes, this is
great. And kind of not realize like all
that, you know, comes along with it. And
uh I share that that story to kind of
help us see our own culture through you
know new eyes. In essence for a lot of
us we just feel you know we just you're
in the culture you're in. So you're just
it's to you and me it's just natural.
You I mean it's just normal. It's like
it's how everyone is. Um but I think it
kind of needs to be asked you know um in
this kind of culture we're living in.
How are we relating and attending to
others? you know, what is our life kind
of about? Are we in a sort of uh almost
a striving, you know, kind of egoic
mode, endlessly like running on that
hideonic treadmill.
Um, and and I think this this kind of
wanting everything for myself uh is kind
of poking um or is a manifestation of,
you know, of that. Uh so that's second,
wanting everything for myself,
acquisition and possession. Third,
wanting to appear important.
We'll call this appearance and
perception.
Anyone you have to again don't have to
raise your hand, but anyone grew up in a
family where appearances were
everything,
you know, like there's certain family
systems are like very much um like this.
I like I said, mine mine is more number
one, the one my own way control and
certain that was more my family did.
This was not our jam. This wasn't our
thing. Um and that's I'm thankful for
that. wasn't my parents weren't big on
like how you come across and don't you
tell others or you know um but woo I've
I know especially I've heard stories
like I've even thinking of someone I
won't say their name but uh someone who
because this really happens a lot in
church almost like at times church makes
this one worse
where um I had a friend and she
would uh or her mom would make her lie
to her grandma about their church
attendance.
So, like when they went to her like
grandma's house, grandma would always
ask like, "How's it how's church going?
How are you enjoying your church?"
And her mom had told her like, "You tell
her yes, we love it. It is great. It's
our favorite place to be every single
Sunday, you know." And of course, they
never went to church. Like, [laughter]
no, it was not a thing. But every Oh,
yes, Grandma. Yes. Oh, is the It is the
best. And uh that's an example, you
know, of kind of how this can uh this
can play out. And I mean, it's it's
really sad because in essence, you know,
church and and such and following Christ
should be the place where we go to uh
drop all that crap. You know what I
mean? like where we we learn to just be
real and authentic and show up just as
our you know true self as best we can
and not precisely not come with oh how
do I look and how is everything going to
you know and trying to be all perfect to
others um but uh instead of this journey
into vulnerability and authenticity it's
so it becomes this sort of ego
strengthening process right trying to
appear more than better than more put
together you know than And I actually um
than I actually am. Um along these
lines, I'll say I do think this is um
one one gift among many, but one gift
that the queer community um offers the
church kind of broadly speaking um well,
not only us, but really everyone. But I
do think most churches um are missing
out on it uh because of, you know, some
of their theology. And what I'm getting
at is like the coming out process is
almost always this kind of, you know,
incredibly courageous
kind of step, you know, into
authenticity,
right? It's this kind of overcoming of
the ego where uh I mean just as I've
I've spoken with with queer folks time
after time the story is they had to
really wrestle with like oh my gosh what
will others think you know what I mean
like that's like a huge deal like what
will my parents think what will my
friends think what will my church
community think might it all just go
away might they all reject me right you
know and it becomes a huge kind of
question And so as they, you know, step
into their queerness, so to speak,
right, embracing that which to the
broader culture, to their family system,
or, you know, whatever makes them
different, um, as they step into that,
it's this um, breakthrough of sorts.
And as they're able to kind of shake
off, you know, the the the chains and
the shackles of kind of their own uh and
even their fear of others, you know,
kind of egoic um critiques and problems
and issues. And I I mean I think this is
like a just a a be like I said just a
beautiful gift that the queer community
is offering the church of kind of like
an example a model of hey not everyone
may love it but you got to be real you
know what I mean like you must be real
it's not worth it to be like fake you
know that's a a huge huge thing and uh
what I've been kind of meditating on is
and what I want to encourage all of us
to do is like okay take that insight
and then keep going.
Like in essence, you know, many of us
have uh maybe you've, you know, come out
as like gay or lesbian or trans or
something or or maybe you come out even
as an ally, you know, and and people
know and there's maybe been some flack,
you know, you've taken for that. Um, but
you know, in other areas of your life,
you may still be like very beholden
to, you know, keeping the image up. Um,
and and kind of your own egoic desire to
be thought well of. So, um, so in
closing, you know, you might kind of
wonder like, okay, well, in light of
these, you know, things like what do I,
what do I do? How do I kind of step in
and, you know, break free? And uh what I
want to suggest, it's not so much about
what we are to do. I think it's more
about um what we are to see. In essence,
there's so much power in simply seeing
these things, observing them, noticing
them in yourself. Does that make sense?
like where we might think sometimes like
I don't know like yeah I need a a like a
practice or a I've got to change all
this overnight and it's it can be quite
daunting you know like oh my gosh I'm
going to like break out of my own ego
it's like every [laughter] everywhere
you um yeah the that's where the trick
is to simply start down that path of
just noticing it kind of noticing when I
want it my way noticing when we want
things for oursel noticing when we're
quite taken with being important and
thought well of and uh I think this is
really good news because you know John
here isn't describing you know it's not
a a battle I think that would be the
wrong metaphor you know for like how do
I fight my ego how do I obliterate you
know like oh no no no this is this is
not the the lens instead um this isn't
about our heroic effort rather it's a
kind of um it's a pattern in ourselves
that we start to learn to notice this is
why I think John writes in verse 17. The
world in all its wanting, wanting,
wanting is on the way out. But whoever
does what God wants is set for eternity.
And eternity here, I think it's not like
some sort of just endless duration of
time, you know, but instead a kind of
endless the endless depths of a life
with God. It's about being rooted in the
present moment. It's it's about a kind
of openheartedness
where love
replaces grasping where um where kind of
presence you know replaces like
performing
now the abundant life that Jesus talked
about can become ours. So
in essence um
I I think to what we need to do is to
kind of deepen our awareness to release
our grasping to grow into this great
love. So to kind of break it down into a
practice um I want to encourage you this
week um anytime you notice just notice
you want it your way want it for
yourself you want to be important you
know take a moment and kind of gently
smile and just release those feelings to
God. You can see where they're where in
that moment of kind of of noticing
again, not fighting it, not like getting
angry at yourself like, "Oh my gosh,
we're such a failure." You know, like,
[laughter] "No, no, no." Just kind of
noticing and like, "Oh, look, I'm doing
it again. Oh my gosh." You know, okay.
Okay. And and a kind of um easy
relationship to it and a kind of
openhearted, open-handed relationship.
Um this uh process of noticing, I think,
is how we, you know, over time and by
the grace um of Christ, we become kind
of less enthralled to the ways of the
world. and uh and more like Jesus in
that process. In the name of the Father,
the Son, and the Holy Spirit. Amen.
So on the night Jesus was betrayed, he
had one final meal with his disciples.
And at that meal, he held a loaf of
bread and he broke it. And he said,
"Take this, eat. This is my body. It's
broken for you." And then he held up a
cup of wine. He said, "Take this drink.
This is my blood. It's shed for you.
Whenever you eat this bread, whenever
you drink this cup, remember me. And so
as we come forward tonight, that's the
practice that we engage connecting with
the Christ who loves us, who welcomes
us, who sees us, and all of our beauty
and our struggles and and all of it. Uh
but but welcomes us um nonetheless.
So the way we'll go about um taking this
tonight is we'll just go rowby row,
starting here at the front, forming one
line in the middle. Um, you can partake
whenever and however you'd like. No one
will lead you through the exact moment
of partaking. Um, the red is wine, the
white is grape juice, and we practice an
open table. So, everyone here tonight is
welcome to uh to participate in this
time. So, this is the table not of the
church, but of the Lord, and it's made
ready for those who love him and for
those who want to love him more. So come
you who have much faith and you who have
little. You who have been here often and
you who have not been here long. You who
have tried to follow and you who feel
like you failed. Come. Come because it's
the Lord Jesus himself who invites you.
And it's his will that those who want to
meet him should meet him here. Come to
the table.
>> [music]
>> Um, we're going to close out with a song
called I'm Letting Go. Um, and the
lyrics of this song were coming to my
mind [music] as Brett was telling me,
kind of what we were going to be um,
focusing on tonight. And just that idea
of surrendering ourself and and giving
over and trusting um trusting ourselves
and and our desires and [music] agendas
and everything over to someone better to
to a God whose ways are good and holy
and pure and and uh trusting him to meet
us there. [music] So if you guys would
like to sit back and um and just take in
these lyrics, you're welcome to do that.
or you can stand and sing along if
[music] you know it. Um or sit and sing
with us. But um let's just reflect on on
that [music] desire to um or or even
just that hope that we can [music]
entrust ourselves in our ways over to
the better ways of God.
You brought me [music] to the end of
myself. [singing]
And this has been the longest road.
Just when [music] my hallelujah
was tired, [singing]
[music] you gave me a new song and I'm
[singing] letting go. [music]
I'm letting go. [singing]
Oh, [music]
[singing] I am letting go. [music]
[singing]
Falling [music]
into
you.
I confess [music]
I still get scared
sometimes.
But [music and singing] perfect love
comes rushing in.
[music] And all the [singing] lies that
screamed inside go silent [music]
the [singing] moment you begin.
[music] So I'm letting go.
[singing]
I'm letting go. [singing]
>> [music]
>> I am letting [singing] go.
Falling [singing and music] in to you.
I'm letting go.
[music]
[singing]
I'm letting go.
Oh,
[singing]
[music]
I'm letting go.
[singing]
[music]
Falling in to you.
Cuz [music] you [singing]
remind me
[music] of things forgotten.
>> [singing]
>> You unwind
me
[snorts] until I'm [music and singing]
totally undone.
And with your arms around me,
fear has no match for [music] your love.
[singing]
And now you've won me.
You [singing]
[music] me
of things forgotten. And you [singing]
unwind me [music]
until I'm totally undone.
And with [singing] your arms [music]
around me,
fear has no match for your love.
[singing] Now [music] you've won me.
And I am letting go.
[singing]
I am letting go. [music and singing]
Oh,
I'm letting
go. [singing]
Falling [music and singing] into
you.
[music]
That was beautiful. Thank you. Thank
[music] you for being here tonight. Your
presence here is such a gift and a lot
of times just showing up helps to build
[music] hope and encouragement for
yourself and for those around you. Um,
if you're new here, uh, we would love it
[music] if you would take a moment to
scan the QR code that's up on the
screen. Fill out the visitor card.
[music] Um, also we have the cards on
the credins over there. You can fill it
out there and put it in the box if you
would rather do that. The QR code is
super [music] helpful. It has a list of
all of our meetups. Uh, it has all of
our coming events. [music]
Um, a great place just to keep a pulse
on what's happening at the table. Um,
don't forget next week 3:30 p.m. [music]
is when we're having service because of
the Super Bowl. 3:30 next week. Uh, also
we have Hat Creek tonight immediately
[music] after the service. We would love
for you to join us there for dinner
afterwards. Um,
if you are able, please [music] rise to
your feet. I would love to send you out
into your [music] week with this
benediction
and these words that I believe are true
[music] for each and every one of you.
You are a child of God.
You are a child [music] of God. This is
true on your best day and [music] it's
true on your worst day.
So, as you go into your week ahead with
its yet [music] to be determined highs
and lows and everything in between,
go filled with the assurance that you
[music] are worthy, you are loved, and
you are accepted just as [music] you
are.
and go filled with God's Holy Spirit and
the desire [music] to extend these same
gifts of grace, compassion, and mercy
[music] to everyone you come in contact
with this week. Be blessed, and we'll
see you at Hack Creek in a few minutes.
Good night.
[music]
And I'm letting [music] go. [singing]